(musique rock)
(déclic et tintement métallique)
- Imaginez...
(en Allemand)
- ...un monde enfin guéri
de la violence.
(bruit métallique)
- Ah!
- J'avoue, ça va être compliqué.
- Pourquoi?
- Parce qu'on va faire
sauter le pont.
(violente détonation)
Parce qu'on a fait sauter
le pont.
(bruyante vibration)
- Vous avez bu un sérum
qui fait de vous des hommes
hors du commun.
- Quoi?
- Vous avez des
capacités psychiques
extraordinaires.
- Ah!
- C'est vraiment de la merde,
ton pouvoir!
- Vous êtes l'espoir
de la Résistance.
- Heil!
- Et si on veut pas
être résistants,
on fait comment?
- Oh!
- Assieds-toi. Ferme ta gueule.
- Il y a des Allemands partout.
- Je les vois rôder autour
de ma putain de maison,
ces salopes.
Fermez vos gueules de cons,
vous pourrez passer la nuit
dans ma grange.
Si vous la salopez,
je vous plombe le cul,
ça vous fera la bitte.
- D'accord.
- Soit vous êtes avec nous,
vous êtes des Résistants,
soit vous êtes avec eux,
et vous êtes des collabos.
(ensemble): Compris!
- Je m'en fous de cette guerre!
- Vous avez tout fait foirer.
Vous tous.
- Et vous, vous y êtes
pour rien?
- Scheisse.
(déclic)
- Ensemble,
on va mettre fin à
cette guerre...
(hurlement)
...une bonne fois
pour toutes.
- Désolé, mais c'est
très con.
Plus con que l'idée de base
qui était déjà très con.
- L'un de vous a d'autres choses
que des idées de con?
- Il faut que la petite merde...
- Scheisse!
- ...devienne...
...un emmerdeur.
- Parfait.
Ils vont morfler,
ces communistes.
- Euh... non, Julot.
C'est les Allemands
qu'il faut combattre.
(léger chuintement):
Bien vu.